as a youngster I'd like to use a
magnifying glass and capture the
sunlight and aim it at insects on the
ground and try them I got a little
braver and my twitch go after singing
insects like bees and wasps and sneak up
on them and then probably their wings
before they could come up at sting me
cuz I know
light had power my name is Jim Wynn and
I'm an expert at laser science and
technology after getting my PhD in
applied physics at Harvard in 1969 I've
been working for IBM research ever since
the laser is a source of light but the
light is coming out in a well-defined
direction with a well-defined coherence
but by the late seventies these new
excimer lasers became commercially
available and I have the good judgment
or wisdom or foresight to buy one for my
group I encourage the people in my group
to think about using excimer lasers
because it had very high power good
short pulses and it worked very well in
the ultraviolet region and the other
lasers we had in our group did not have
been ultraviolet light
dr. Rangaswamy Srinivasan recognized
that when he shined that laser light on
a piece of plastic that it was
photo-etch the plastic pulse by pulse
each pulse of light would take off a
minut amount of material and the depth
of the hole would be proportional to the
number of pulses that he used three and
I started talking about would we be able
to use this in some surgical application
the concept was not that far-fetched but
now we had to test it out the
breakthrough was three brought his
leftover Thanksgiving turkey into the
lab and he made a very clean incision in
some cartilage on the bone of his
leftover Thanksgiving turkey when I saw
the incision made by the excimer laser
that was what I call my aha moment my
mind was thinking this laser is the best
clean scalpel that you can imagine it
was really conceivable we had a new form
of surgery
thief joke l an ophthalmologist from
Columbia University Medical Center came
here to the Watson Research Center with
some nucleated calf eyes from slaughter
and with our laser we made clean
incisions in the cornea and the
incisions were just ultra clean there
was no evidence of collateral damage and
the race was on to develop laser
effective surgery in lasik you more or
less have complete perfect vision by the
next day I am very proud of the fact
that something that started off as just
a fun experiment turned into something
that could help so many millions of
people you know science is an endless
frontier and engineering is an endless
frontier when you put the two together
and go in the right direction you can
make some really magical things happen
you